hey conan yeah you were talking to bob
about being an action star do you
ever wish that you could be an action
star i'm sorry are you laughing i'm so
why'd you laugh as you asked it it's a
legitimate question i couldn't even get
through the question
well no i mean because first of all i
think what bob has done for people like
me is he's he's opened a door
which is bob was very no seriously bob
was very established in comedy
and then he went this other way and it's
a huge hit and he's a big success
i feel like people are going to come
calling now because
as you can attest matt and sona i take
very good
care of my body i'm i'm cut like a
diamond
and i think you could play plastic
man
[Laughter]
well you know what is funny i was
thinking i would love to be in an action
movie and play it completely seriously
and i'm just putting this idea out there
if there are any
producers or finance seers anything like
anyone
i have very long legs so i'd like to
play an action star whose thing is that
my lower half like literally from the
waist down
my legs are very long and they can do
amazing things and they
they whip around they're almost like
whips and they're doing all these
incredible
and and they're zipping around and
flying around and and knocking
bad guys out but from the waist up i'm
completely immobile
and i show very little emotion you're
like an upside down helicopter yeah i'm
like an upside down helicopter and so
[Laughter]
so i'm a guy who not unlike bob i've got
this
nine to five life and women don't really
pay attention to me and bully's always
i'm sort of put upon and people tease me
and i put up with it
and then finally there's this gang and
they're giving me a hard time and i snap
and you see me take my arms and hold on
to either side of those
those uh grab bars that they have on the
subway i hold on so that i secure my
upper body
i don't my face doesn't move and then
you hear uh
and my lower body starts whipping around
and you see
bad guys flying left and right and
yeah and then later on the police show
up and the coroner's like they've all
been killed with size 12 feet
you kill them all oh they're all dead no
they're dead
and then and then it comes out they
weren't even threatening me that much
they were trying to ask me directions oh
you're just a murderer then
i'm just a guy who thought i'm overly
sensitive a leg murderer
it turns out it was a bunch of 17 year
olds just looking for directions to the
metropolitan museum of art
and i was like i can take no more and i
grab onto the grab rails and
and my legs just start spinning at like
180 miles an hour in every different
direction they're like egg beaters
and uh the kids are just matt the kids
are massacred
and uh yeah it's just
brutal and gruesome yeah what's this
movie called
whirligig
[Laughter]
it's the whirler gig this is an awful
action
this is the best oh someone's jealous
that i have my franchise and you haven't
thought of yours
oh yeah leg killer that's a great
franchise
well yeah it just it's just from the
waist down
uh he's a he's your worst nightmare from
the waist
up uh not much has happened you know